juni das sehr denn die
panik ist oxid ja ich weiß nicht was da
alles fähig
irgendein thema stalking und trafen
münchen wo verzeichnet was für ein floß
der psychoterror ruf ihres
inszeniert ihre energie
nicht das recht kontakt mit dem wir
anderen zahlen ganz so einfach ist es
aber nicht stock in der schweiz kein
eigener straftatbestand
strafbar sind nun einige wie zum
beispiel ruhigen und körperverletzung
was oft schmerzlich was
[Musik]
mit sandra sonderlich keinen als
verbündete schulzeit und sie statt
sachlich über mehrere jahre hinweg
stockt wurde ich habe so schnell wachsen
im büro vor kurzem wo ich sondern der
treffer haben hat sich mir anvertraut
ich kann mir verzählt dass ich reportage
zum thema stalking machen sandras
bereite die geschichte zu zählen
allerdings nur der anfang
mittlerweile hat die frisch facebook
geschickt
neben agnes nicht kennt aber
noch richtig liebe
dass es sich so eines anonymus
das landschafts vettel ist viel geld für
ihr name
x-beliebigen name plus
freunde wirklich so also nicht
gemerkt dass das 180 viele nachrichten
vorlagen
der blauregen bochum besteht aber
entgangen oder kompliment
ich habe nicht wirklich als kompliment
empfunden haben
zumindest
durch so eine schöne frau durch so einen
tollen körper
wahnsinnig www gute
zwei monate lang hatte man immer
zugeschrieben und bilder geschickt und
alles und da nicht der polizei mal
blüten und halt verzählt dem restaurant
tipp mieter über facebook zum teil
selbst mal am tag nachricht geschickt
kompliment macht
und ich habe nicht wissen wir dass ich
glaubte den job blog ja was denn will
kommt man da nicht sagt ja
das ist so oder so sachen wie katja das
ist nicht
illegal
da kann man nicht machen
nur durch den stich auch uns noch nie
ich habe gespürt dass da nicht okay ich
was er macht und so machtlos denn du das
segment das mit der polizei damals nicht
unterstützt hätte
es passieren dass irgend so lässt also
muss es denn dazu holte
sexuell belästigt oder dass er doch
nicht einfach und unerlaubtem ist das
nach eigener beseitigt etwas falsches
gemacht
wie sie mir jetzt im gespräch zeit ist
andere zu dem zeitpunkt 10x so belastend
dass alles ist bis zu dem punkt der
täter mit seiner handlichkeit grenze wo
die legalität mit überschritten und
somit einen strafbar gemacht wie sie von
offizieller seite hilfe holt den sitz
auch sabri tanz und schrieb ihren
stalker soll sie in ruhe
erfolglos situation ist kurz zu haben
nur schlimmer wurden bildet jetzt sind
wir nicht sie sind pornographisch
verschiedene
positionen da irgendwie sehr fest
wenn man denn die klinik sieht also mit
oben ohne
schlammschlacht war die grünen
augenbrauen da kann also ganze
datenbank auf dem pc mit
ihm zog es vor die vom iran dazu mit das
ist ja mega klubs haben sich alter nicht
so mit verschiedenen zugleich hätte die
fläche von facebook inc
nein die meisten väterlich aus dem zug
oder erich facebook profil von meinen
kollegen aus öffentlicher hand wo ich
irgendwann mal kekse oder
er hat einfach noch mit namen googelt
und denen wir von einem sportverein oder
sowas mannschaft heute sehe ich hätte
muss knete darf
panik
was wenn der wert der mann schau und es
sieht ja ich weiß nicht so was ihr alles
weg ich will dass ich unbedingt die
grenze überschritten wird fast paranoid
wenn man immer das muss gott und dank
und respekt über wenig dann zog sätze
oder filmt die stadt laufen und das hat
man dann natürlich angst macht natürlich
weiß nicht vielleicht irgendwann lange
dem das auge ja
[Musik]
dann eingeschlafen und alles
lief erzählt dass ich so viel wie es
nachher zieht die blockiert und kurz
drauf aber noch nicht auf eine neue
profile gehackt nachricht es gibt immer
kassel wurde ihre hilflosigkeit
mandelson doppelt erotica
zusammen mit sandra absuche immer die
frau wo sich damals im fall
corinna starke stalking betroffene
menschen betreut allein jahr zwar keine
20,52 xxi ich hatte angst
dank dass ich vielleicht gar nicht so
schlimm wenn ich meine richter nicht
auffällig überreagieren das hat mir
damals eine art bietet mir das so gut
dass ich mich verändert hat und seit mai
das ist falsch dass die person macht ja
und das finde ich einfach wahnsinnig was
das mit einem aus stellt dem kopf in das
er heute immer noch mit aber überlege
jetzt machen wir den betrag nach
gesamtes gut im fernseh und flächen dank
audiolith
was tut sie so
ja ich dachte so schlimm das ist für
mich da wieder raus ich mach mich selber
ich denke
du welche eigentlich selber das ist
falsch ich wie so ziemlich den gliedern
ja
es ist interessant das ist ganz super
steht wenn es ist oft so das passiert
über jahre oder
nimmt aus mitte zieht war aus es ist so
und es ich kann es nicht andere es macht
einen auch bis hilflos wie immer für
zwei flöten oder
als auch sammler sind häufig mit der
polizei aber schönheit einer frau
begegnet übernahme sind polizei deiner
situation an bord
also was schwierigkeit bei der polizei
ist das stalking ist natürlich noch kein
straftatbestand in der schweiz ich
bekannt das ist für polizei menschen
schwierig ist wenn über jeden tag rose
vor der tür light oder brieflich im
briefkasten feucht mal total öde
ungefragt päckchen schickt oder was auch
immer dass ich alles richtig
das ist psychoterror dass dort ein
mensch noch für zwiebeln oder nicht
das tue es freut mich zwar verschwindet
das haben wir auch sehr gut verstehen
aber schwierigkeit für polizei und führt
strafbehörde ist natürlich gibt es einen
straftatbestand
und wenn kein straftatbestand
ersichtlich ist denn sind an der polizei
und der strafbehörde entbunden der
sonderfall hat es dort ganz klar
überschritten aber zu denken wir später
wenn ich jetzt aus es war halt ein
straftatbestand und wenn nicht mehr hand
auf dem kanal und beruf gemacht und
personen zu finden wo schon mal gestoppt
wurden sind also schwierig sie die falle
schätze ist das stalking oder einfach
nur nachwuchs verhalten zum beispiel
schrieb sofia auf rezept täglich folgte
mir unbemerkt und schoss fotos die in
kurze zeit später wieder per whatsapp
schickte mit den kommentaren wie das ist
dann wird ein schönes kleid oder du
solltest die haare öfter zu tragen sie
seither wieder sehr gruselig gefunden
aber sie hat dann probiert sich zu
wehren sich zu der polizei gegangen und
danach dem ist ein absturz um die person
über als blockierer und sie hat im
zittern mimik see und an mit mir vorhin
kürt dann schreibt er jogge ich wurde
jahrelang es dort von meiner ex bis ich
irgendwann den mut gefunden habe zur
polizei zu gehen mir war das so peinlich
damals er sei dass sie eine sehr große
energie aber dass er angst gehabt und
das rra paranoid aber dass es als mal
einfach schwerer stack wieland glaubt
wird die ich habe gut vorstellen dass
man als mann mit zur toxische klischees
konfrontiert wird wer du bist heute mal
du musst stärker sie durch eine frau
körperlich überlegen aber ich glaube an
gott
das stalking
psychische belastung ist und das ist
nicht nur um körperliche überlegenheit
gott mir lantus erfinder die film mann
der im vergleich zu frauen für stalking
betroffen sind für die schweiz geht so
leider keine positive zahlen in
deutschland ist stark in gesetzen
eigenen straftatbestandes konsum
einfacher ausgewiesen werden letzte als
in deutschland
2440 stalking polizeilich erfasst wurde
80 prozent der betroffenen sind frauen
ich kann das gut vorstellen dass schauen
wie man eine große rolle spielt und
rundgang mit dem focus dass dunkelziffer
höher ist damit doch normal am kiosk
er schrieb dass der igora sie und dass
er schon seit 25 jahren
verfolgt würde die das düstere brief sie
blüten und dafür musste oft auch dass
seine konstant sondern das remis immer
wieder zu ihm alle und letzte winter zu
im november dezember 21 ist sehr schlimm
sei das verhalten der frau diego
belastete solarzellen wir merken schon
vor dem gespräch mit ihm das sinnvoll
schwierig einzuordnen ist es ist
zumindest klar ersichtlich ob ein
straftatbestand vorliegt ich glaube ich
in der recherche sind als miri sofa
begegnet und bewies laut denkt sie ist
wie man es erfinden wir diego mit dem
gott
der gorges dass er frauen belästigt vor
rund 25 jahren keine clio tg nach hinten
aushilft und zeigt auf seine ski und
umsatz frisch maxi du bist der erste
mini sehr berührt hat liebe vor deiner
idee wartet sie sich über jahrzehnte
hinweg immer wieder mini cooper telefon
muss schriftlich er zeigt dass all die
briefe und postkarten bewertet leider
sieht das für mich nicht so aus als ob
du nur ein gedanke nicht verschwenden
würdest erscheint mir als ob ich das
optisch meiner existenz und alles was zu
mir gehört nicht mehr den geringsten
interessiert ich war es zwar gewohnt
dass du im herbst 98 aufgehört hast
offen mit mir zu sprechen bewusstes es
würde ich damit umgehen kann dass du
einen freund hast ich träumte auch doch
schon davon dass ich dich in pohritzsch
am strand mit einer frau sauer und du
mich provozieren dann saß ich mit der
frau dass sie weiß das nicht aber es gab
einfach nicht akzeptieren zitiert er
geht wieder gesagt hast dass du an
frauen interessiert ihn heute dass wir
sie halten das für schreter sich im
urlaub ich habe meinen mann geburtstag
eine woche ferien werde
höchstwahrscheinlich abhauen kommst du
mit bitte bitte bitte bekommst einen
anderen mitnehmen wird schon gehen bin
erträglich und werde euch keine reifen
liefern
doch durch macht nach als bauherr jeden
und ihren umgang tötet man gespürt
monate lang gut denn marie hieß es
weiter vor der halle johann suck
belästigungen den künftigen geschrieben
und ausgeschenkt didacta sinne augusto
deponiert als ich das letzte mal
angerufen habe und fragte ob du zeit für
mich hat das sagst du nein definitiv
nein später hast du mich in whatsapp
blockiert aber darauf du weißt ja dass
ich nicht wieder mit direktor weiß dass
ich alles drin das ist alles da das ist
das erste zu erlaufen kann ich meine
versteckt
davis ich glaube ich ganz gut damit wenn
dann merkst dass du so rath und weißt du
wenn sie so bald und den steg ist
weniger gut weg sagt mit acht regionale
erzeugnisse und habe mir echt möge
distanzierte jegliche energie und es
wird so weitergehen
das ist auch der punkt es wird so
weitergehen
und das ist auch das ist
also jederzeit wieder tun der ego
befindet sich in einer nahaufnahme lag
in der rechtlichen grauzone singstar
queen ist sehr aufdringlich aber
überschreitet sie erachte ich die ganze
wir fragen uns ob diego sektor dazu
schon professionell ihm eine gekonnt
hätte
aber es ist ein guter weg das
will will da
sie hat ruhig da und dann nicht prag ich
dir rufen wertverlust hast du
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht verbote oder
was auch immer und
handelstage du hättest natürlich ist
aber auch immer im hinterkopf die person
geht es
darum dass die schulter nach alba setzte
und so wie sie funktioniert zunächst
bleibt dass sie funktioniert ist jede
aufmerksamkeit wo sie von mir bekommt
diesen trick ist für sie wie
nektar
vier wochen später im eco ev stimmt das
nachtanken druck während der recherche
ist dass es viele stalking fall geht was
auch ältere grauzonen abspielen und
weniger sättigung klarer straftatbestand
wie beispielsweise körperverletzung oder
ruhigen erfüllt werden haben wir deine
verwirklichen hutmacher levante rat von
experten die halle diego regie bestanden
und routen ja das problem ich habe nie
damit befasst
was
weder aufgeregt und gespannt
mit la verziehen ihm selber in der
kanzlei buse schaffen die staatsanwalt
in mit expertise im stroh fracht diego
für zeltner und was er in den letzten
gut 25 jahre erlebte vor der brief von
der arie und das im letzten winter auf
ostdeutschland um in persönlicher beats
bringen
als ich das letzte mal angerufen habe
und fragte ob du zeit für mich hasst
sagte c't du nein definitiv nein später
hast du mich im whatsapp blockiert damit
werden natürlich auch die
verhaltensweise wo sie ihre gebrauchten
nehmen wir das über den kontakt wünscht
werde klar umschrieben
es gibt verhaltensweisen sind für sie
strafbar als jedes einzelnen handelt für
sich nutzer strafbar wie zum beispiel
missbrauch von ra fernmelder das heißt
wenig wie oft ich ganz viel arroganz
vielleicht als mit dem handy zu dem
buschwerk wären nicht mit inbegriffen
wie seine schilderungen wo sie jetzt
macht endlich im
wahlkampf strafwürdig und da ist er also
oder gebe es einzelne für sich noch
nicht strafbar risiko nicht einzelne
straftatbestand wie zum beispiel ruhig
oder körperverletzung frage kommt ist es
schwieriger bis ausrichten allerdings
können auch nicht strafbare handlung
strafbar war wenn sie die betroffene
person über einen längeren zeitraum
belästigen dann kann das als nötigung
aus leitfaden luthe sinne selber gab es
auch möglichkeit sie widerrechtlich sco
und präventives kontaktverbot zurück
trotzdem flott - weil es nicht einfacher
stalking als straftatbestand werden
praktisch
wie sichere ganz wichtig in praktischer
das jetzt juristisch neuen
straftatbestand integrieren oder nötig
für mich wie irrelevant welthit wie
schon strafbar der go ahead die außerdem
schoss rackert im fußball einfach wie
stalking so lange dauert es sehr wichtig
dass da keine grenzen setzen das heißt
klar sagen dass man den kontakt nicht
wett und das am besten schriftlich
festhalten
dann muss
man kann also abbau zu einer
touristischen bis richter ganz so
einfach das aber doch nicht ein großteil
der verantwortung liegt wie der
betroffenen prozent die emotionale und
zeitliche ressourcen und hat zum
business talk netz unternehmen und dann
wenn sie an ob sie der hand haben um
besser in form von babys sowie sandra
sie hat ihre täter letztendlich doch nun
sagt erich röß zuvor bestraft wurde
haben wir dann noch mal wenn ein blick
auf die wache startet so der
beschuldigte hat vorsätzlich das heißt
mit wissen und willen jemanden in große
reise durch worte sexuell belästigt
deniz naki pornografie
muss darum gegangen ist dass die person
vorsätzlich
material
gestellt
das heißt eigentlich dass er damals die
konkrete situation hat facebook braucht
hat zur beunruhigung oder zur
belästigung
die jahre hin
zum urteil dass andere story museums
wölfli mehr als 900 franken zahlen im
nachhinein finde
vier jahrhunderte immer wieder
engagiert gemacht hat findet er wenig
für die betroffene person ich das
strafmaß
dass ich sie jetzt viel gemacht das was
sie erlebten über so lange zeit das
kommende das ist in keinem verhältnis
und da sich in kürze
auf dvd
das ist durchaus möglichkeiten geht es
um rechtliche stalking keine vor ca was
also ist ein gespräch mit der choriner
straße berg leben ist ich das super
wichtig ist dass man bewiesen wieder
einmal so sache hat dann hat man noch
viel größer die chance zur königin die
stalkerinnen unternehmen übrigens geht
stopp bestrebungen zu dem thema im
parlament
wir stehen die töpfe schauen wie ich bin
ist ruhig oder nötigung und jetzt schon
im strafgesetzbuch sind sollen in
zukunft ganz klare und zwar mit
verhaltens lisa wie flure oder noch
schneller erholt stalking im herbst soll
zudem ein vorentwurf gemacht werden und
jetzt wäre als wundermann heimische
erfahrungen mit stalking machen main
event könnt ihr das gerne der kommentare
vor verteilen und wenn wir schon mal da
sind abonnieren doch der kanal es gibt
jede zweite neue reportage